Faire de l'histoire ce n'est pas forcément
retenir des dates par cœur
visiter des abbayes cisterciennes et
arpenter les rayons de bibliothèques.
Il y a de ça, oui, mais pas que.
On peut faire de l'histoire, aimer cette science
sans passer nécessairement par la science
justement.
Ce que je veux dire,
c'est qu'il existe des
passerelles pour apprendre et s'intéresser
aux choses.
Youtube en est une, et c'est d'ailleurs
sans doute pour ça que vous êtes là devant
votre écran à m'écouter
mais il en existe
d'autres et la Science, les sciences ne seraient
rien sans ces passerelles.
Qu'est-ce-que j'entends par passerelles ?
Des
moyens et des supports pour communiquer une
information assez simple, parfois créatifs
ou artistiques :
vidéo, voyage, lecture,
réseaux sociaux, musique.
Si je vous dis que je me suis intéressée
à Pompéi,
non pas par mes études en archéologie
mais grâce à Pink Floyd.
Oui, oui, le groupe de rock psyché des années
60-70.
Il y a peu de chance que vous fassiez le lien
à moins d'être un fan inconditionnel du
groupe ou bien d'être né dans ces années
là.
Donc en 1972 Pink Floyd privatise Pompéi,
donne un concert dans l'amphithéâtre de
la cité et ce sans public :
le groupe joue
seul au milieu des ruines
ah et avec un chien aussi !
La même année, le film sort au cinéma
qui mixe plans du live, scènes en studios
et effets spéciaux bien psyché.
C'est de cette façon que j'ai redécouvert
Pompéi, m'y suis attachée et décidé de
vous présenter ce lieu.
Pompéi est une cité romaine antique située
en Campanie à quelques kilomètres au sud
de Naples : on y va en train, en longeant
la côte, c'est très joli.
Elle est entièrement détruite et ensevelie
par les cendres de l'éruption du Vésuve
en 79 ap.J.-C.
Un bouchon de lave explose, libérant
un immense nuage de plusieurs dizaines de
km de hauteur en forme de champignon que les
spécialistes appellent « le panache volcanique».
Les cendres s'empilent sur une épaisseur
d'environ 3 mètres,
l'air est irrespirable
et la région est plongée dans une nuit qui
durera plusieurs jours.
Les villes de Pompéi, d'Herculanum et de
Stabies sont rayées de la carte et on estime
qu'un dixième de la population de la région
a péri durant l'éruption.
Voilà pour les présentations très générales
que vous devez sans doute connaître en partie.
A force de lier le nom de la cité de Pompéi
à la catastrophe, on en vient presque à
oublier son histoire, son organisation, son
rôle commercial, ses habitants.
On l'enferme dans une catégorie macabre,
mais Pompéi n'est pas une nécropole !
Alors c'est quoi Pompéi avant le drame ?
Et bien, ça va peut être vous étonner mais
Pompéi, peu avant sa destruction, est une
ville en chantier.
Les dernières découvertes archéologiques
montrent que la ville a subi plusieurs séismes
avant 79 qui ont détruit une partie des habitations.
Il faut donc imaginer que les habitants de
Pompéi vivaient, avant l'éruption, au milieu
des ruines et des bâtiments en reconstruction.
A la suite de ces tremblements de terre qui
ont lieu 16 ou 17 ans avant l’ensevelissement
de la ville, on a préféré réutiliser les
matériaux des constructions détruites :
on le voit particulièrement dans les tavernes
où les marbres des comptoirs sont des réemplois
des matériaux des anciens bâtiments.
Plutôt que de reconstruire toutes les maisons
et villas touchées par les séismes on a
préféré, dans l'urgence, en raser une partie
pour aménager des espaces verts et des jardins
privés.
On comprend qu'au moment de l'éruption Pompéi
est dans une situation assez exceptionnelle
en pleine reconstruction, marquée par des
séismes à répétition.
On s'éloigne donc peu à peu de la vision
romantique, souvent donnée, d'une ville riche
et prospère, conservée intacte par les cendres
c'est une erreur de la considérer comme
un exemple parfait de la cité antique.
Pompéi n'était pas une cité aussi importante
qu'on le dit, en tous cas moins que Naples
par exemple.
C'est plus la région, la Campanie tout entière
qui est riche et célèbre :
les terres sont fertiles
ce qui en fait le premier grenier
à blé de l'Italie et lui donne une place
majeure dans le commerce international.
Pompéi est une ville modeste qui s’insère
dans ce système-là en exportant notamment
sa production de vin.
Pourtant, on connaît surtout Pompéi pour
ses fresques, ses mosaïques, ses objets en
bronze et en argent, ses sculptures, ses fontaines.
Bref les œuvres d'art qui témoignent de
la richesse de leurs propriétaires.
La ville
accueille en fait à cette époque une élite
qui possède de grands domaines agricoles.
Mais la plupart d'entre eux ne résident pas
à l'année à Pompéi
ils exploitent le sol
en faisant travailler des esclaves et
des fermiers qu'ils rémunèrent.
Pompéi, c'est un peu le Saint-Trop de l'Antiquité,
les riches y viennent en villégiature, se
faisant construire de somptueux appartements
attenants à leur ferme et ceux qui vivent
et travaillent réellement à l'année sont
moins bien lotis.
Même si on a retrouvé une quantité incroyable
d'objets durant les fouilles, il faut bien
avoir à l'esprit que Pompéi a subi un pillage
considérable durant des siècles, en particulier
les lieux publics comme le Forum.
On a donc beaucoup de mal à restituer de
manière fiable ce qu'était la cité au
1er siècle de notre ère.
On sait que le site a été fréquenté jusqu’au
4ème siècle et puis il est tombé dans l'oubli,
une grande partie des vestiges ne faisant
pratiquement plus surface.
Ce n'est que vers 1600 que la cité antique
est découverte mais elle ne sera identifiée
qu'en 1748.
Le dégagement du site commence de façon
assez anarchique et peu scrupuleuse dès 1765.
Très vite les squelettes exhumés des victimes
font l'attraction du site
on hésite pas à mettre en scène des fouilles
où on découvre
ces squelettes lors de la venue de personnalités
célèbres.
Le tournant scientifique s'opère grâce à
Giuseppe Fiorelli qui prend la direction des
fouilles de Pompéi et d'Herculanum dès 1860.
Pour la première fois, une équipe scientifique
est déployée et Fiorelli se fait connaître
en mettant au point une méthode pour mouler
les corps des victimes.
Cette technique consiste à verser du plâtre
dans les espaces creux des couches de cendres,
espaces auparavant occupés par des corps
humains ou animaux.
Pompéi et les cités voisines représentent
une étape clé dans l’histoire de l’archéologie,
celle d’une première approche scientifique
avec les prémices de la stratigraphie.
C’est l'étude des couches sédimentaires.
Un bon exemple est celui des fouilles des
maisons
auparavant, on les dégageait de
manière anarchique en commençant par les
côtés jusqu’à l’arrivée de Fiorelli
où on comprit qu’il fallait toujours commencer
par le haut puis descendre couche par couche
c'est le principe n°1 de l'archéologie
puisque plus vous descendez plus c'est ancien.
Il faut bien comprendre qu'avant Pompéi,
l’archéologie concentre essentiellement
des collectionneurs.
Au 18ème siècle, les ruines antiques font
partie du paysage mais n'intéressent essentiellement
que des artistes comme Piranèse.
L’archéologie naît de la découverte ou
plutôt de la redécouverte de Pompéi.
Ce site archéologique constitue, au fil des
années, un laboratoire où on élabore
des techniques de fouille mais aussi des moyens
de conservation et de restauration.
S'étendant sur environ 65 ha
on estime que
trois cinquième de sa superficie totale ont
été dégagés.
Pompéi est en réalité
le plus grand musée du monde !
Si la cité a disparu en 79, sa mise au jour
et son ouverture au public depuis le 18ème
signent sa seconde mort
les vestiges, et
en particulier les fresques murales sont endommagés
à mesure que les touristes affluent sur le
site.
Ce processus de dégradation, qui couvre d'un
étrange voile blanc les peintures des villas,
autrefois éclatantes, est certes progressif
mais inévitable.
Les archéologues ont donc décidé de ne
pas fouiller le reste de la cité et, ce,
pour deux raisons : éviter la dégradation
des ruines qui restent pour l'instant protégées
par la couche de cendres, et laisser des vestiges
aux archéologues du futur.
Si vous visitez un jour Pompéi ou Herculanum
(qui est d’ailleurs bien mieux conservée),
sachez bien qu'il ne s'agit pas de l'état
antique de ces villes.
Après les fouilles, et c'est normal, les
sites ont été aménagés, adaptés au tourisme
de masse qui les caractérisent aujourd'hui.
De nombreux édifices ont été reconstruits,
par exemple après les bombardements allemands
de 1943.
On a solidifié et arrangé les murs avec
des matériaux modernes, on a ajouté des
toitures pour protéger les décorations,
on a renommé des rues et des maisons pour
faciliter la circulation, etc.
Cela est certes essentiel à la conservation
du site, mais ça témoigne aussi d'une démarche,
d'une façon d'envisager l'histoire, et de
valoriser le patrimoine.
Une démarche qu'on pourrait résumer ainsi
: faire visiter, montrer au plus grand nombre,
au prix d'une altération du site, d'une modification
de son état originel.
Si certains s'en émeuvent au nom de l'exactitude
historique, ce que je peux comprendre, je
pense que permettre au plus grand nombre de
visiter ces ruines est l'un des seuls moyens
de transmettre une réelle connaissance à
leur sujet.
La connaissance a besoin de l'émotion qui
est attachée au lieu, et il faut pour la
ressentir, s'y rendre physiquement.
Cette démarche est en définitive une métaphore
de la vulgarisation : adaptons le message
scientifique pour mieux le transmettre.
Et c'est aussi ce qui m'avait vraiment séduite
dans le live de Pink Floyd : la façon de
se réapproprier un lieu, l'amphithéâtre
antique, en respectant son rôle, celui d'accueillir
un spectacle mais cette fois avec des instruments
électriques.
Par le son, faire de nouveau vibrer les murs
de la cité.
Mon travail depuis plus d'un an c'est justement
la vulgarisation
présenter la réalité scientifique le plus simplement possible
en m'efforçant de ne pas tomber dans les
pièges audio-visuels du reportage avec une
musique de film à suspense, insistant sur
le caractère secret, caché des civilisations
disparues...
Les sujets archéologiques sont très souvent
traités sous le prisme de la catastrophe,
Pompéi en étant le parfait exemple.
Mais l’archéologie dans ce marketing audiovisuel
est à part, tout simplement parce que c’est
une science, et vendre l’archéologie comme
on vendrait un film d'action ça pose problème
Alors comment raconter l'Histoire sans raconter
des histoires, des histoires édulcorées
ou catastrophiques ?
Et bien ce n'est pas toujours évident !
Pour chaque vidéo, j'essaye de faire quelque
chose qui me plaît tout en pensant à vous
qui la regarderez, en espérant que ça vous
sera utile, un peu comme un cadeau.
Il m'arrive souvent de douter avant la publication
d'un épisode, persuadée que ce ne sera pas
assez alléchant
et heureusement vous êtes
au rdv et vos commentaires m'encouragent chaque
fois à recommencer.
Alors merci, merci d'être
là,
de regarder, d'écrire, de partager,
de liker, de tiper et par là de faire vivre
la chaîne !
J'espère que ce contenu vous
inspire, vous fait voyager quelques instants
et vous donne envie d'apprendre d'une autre
manière.
Je vous souhaite à toutes et à tous une
très belle année 2018 !